we had five bananas with polka dots and
Rudy does not like bananas with polka
dots and there's no way I can finish
five bananas in one day so we're gonna
make banana
bread because when life gives you
bananas with polka dots you make banana
I don't usually use oil with breads or
pancakes or whatever so we use some
applesauce I blended up some oats to
make my flour we're gonna make it to
protein with some almond powder I put in
like four eggs thankfully our chickens
like this I'm gonna just wing it with
the Almond whatever this is the word
escapes me and then if I need more then
I can just blend up some more oats or
add more milk we're gonna score a little
bit of vanilla just again wing it
because I Wing everything and then we're
going to add some baking powder and I'm
gonna add my Blended up smoothie looking
mixture now I'll just spray it with my
reusable oil spray bottle then we'll pop
it in the oven at 350 degrees until the
knife or toothpick comes out to clean
the chocolate was meant to make it onto
the molds but it looks like John's uh
most of them are making it in his mouth